rise and shine it's n spresso time good
morning believe nation its Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded onto the
world so grab your coffee and sip on
today's message believe in your mission
over to you Mark Zuckerberg when I was
here three years ago they were calling
you the toddler CEO and they don't say
that anymore at all this is a tough
question but try hey how would you grade
yourself as a CEO as the leader of this
business I mean that is a hard crash a
hard question I also don't think you can
ever win by answering that question now
we've made a huge number of mistakes
along the way
right now I I always say I just think
we've made probably every possible
mistake you could make is there a
decision that you've made that the
people around you told you was a mistake
and you defied them and you were right
you know I mean the most famous one I
think probably has to do with selling
the company right I mean in 2006 right
we're this opportunity to sell the
company to Yahoo for a billion dollars
and we we turn that down I think a lot
of people at the time thought that we
should sell the company have somebody
you know I I felt really strongly and I
think like now people generally think
that that was a good decision since that
decision the company has grown
considerably estimates are that if there
were an initial public stock offering an
IPO today Facebook would be valued
between 35 and 50 billion dollars are
you ever going to have the IPO ever you
know like maybe it let go you can't let
go you can't let go I don't think it's
letting go here's the way that I think
about it a lot of people who I think
build startups their companies think
that's selling the company or going
public
is this endpoint where it's like you win
when you go public and that's just not
how I see it raise your standard Apple
at the core its core value is that we
believe that people with passion and not
one drop of my self-worth depends on
your acceptance of me I don't ever give
up I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
roses success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link the
description for details